if you imagine a curve you start here a
little bit above the line at uninformed
optimism is that you see your buddies
doing Drop Shipping and he's making
money and so you're like wow this must
be amazing I will do that too you start
doing that then you move to stage two so
you go over the hump of excitement and
then you go to informed pessimism now
you're below the line then you're like
wow there's a lot of other stuff that's
really competitive I don't have a brand
it's hard to differentiate you know the
cost of goods is actually continuing to
rise and so are ad costs and you start
realizing the other things that you
didn't know before so you have a
slightly more realistic view of the
opport then you go to stage three which
is the value of Despair where you're
like nothing's working I don't know what
I'm doing and this point is where
everyone then jumps to uninformed
optimism in the next opportunity and
they repeat 1 2 3 until they're
eventually able to learn that they just
need to stomach because every single
business has and when the grass is
green on the other side it's because
there's lots of manure there same as
yours and then you go up to informed
optimism and then you hit achievement